[Applause]
yeah i mean as you can see this is a
hugely emotional moment for
uh arthur's grandmother who you can see
there as well as
uh other neighbors there's at least two
or three hundred people here who had all
just let off the balloons here and as
you say
to remember uh the happier times that uh
arthur
had in his short life we're about 20 or
30 meters or so actually away from the
house
uh where he suffered
so awfully the family did not want
this vigil to take place there
you can hear
a round of applause now
to remember
a six-year-old who
went through such horror
and
[Applause]
throughout uh the last hour or so there
have been
people continuing to lay flowers at the
house children coming to
put toys in front of the house obviously
an incredibly
upsetting and moving occasion
some of uh the balloons and and tributes
are being taken down by family and
friends to the house here the whole road
has come to an absolute standstill
and that's the moment you can hear there
[Applause]
of the balloons being let off
that's a difficult moment of course this
comes under the backdrop of
this national review as we were just
hearing about there but for the
community here and for the family this
is simply a moment now to remember
you